ethiopia's government has declared a
national state of emergency and ordered
residents of addis ababa to prepare to
defend their neighborhoods as the grain
forces make rapid gains and advance
towards the capital
fighters from the northern tigrai region
say they have seized two cities about
400 kilometers away from addis ababa the
rebels have been locked in a brutal war
with government forces since last year
and the conflict has plunged hundreds of
thousands of people integra into famine
left thousands of civilians dead and
forced millions to flee their homes
just days after the latest deadly
airstrike in the tigrian capital the
ethiopian government is warning that
fighting may soon reach ethiopia's
capital city addis ababa some residents
fear the advance to grind fighters who
are now reported less than 250 miles
from the capital others support the
government's decision
the state of emergency is to protect the
nation's existence unity and sovereignty
with security
[Music]
i do not think it will harm or benefit
any individuals
as
well after a year of brutal fighting
thousands of civilians are dead while
millions have had to flee their homes
the un has warned that all sites in the
conflict have committed severe abuses
all parties to the tigray conflict have
committed violations of international
human rights humanitarian and refugee
law
some of these may amount to war crimes
and crimes against humanity but with
soldiers on the move and both sides
showing no willingness to compromise the
ethiopians caught in the middle will
continue to suffer
elizabeth rossell is a spokesperson for
the united nations human rights office
and she joins us now from geneva
switzerland
i'm going to start right off the bat
with you how worried are you about the
situation in ethiopia because we're
getting reports that rebels of the
tagraya people's liberation front
say they are close to capturing addis
ababa
well it is clearly a very worrying
situation and it's deteriorating
and this underscores the the importance
of what we've been saying today that
during the conflict which began last
november
the all parties to the conflict have
committed violations violations such as
attacks on civilians extrajudicial
killings torture and of course rape lots
of sexual violence and gender-based
violence against women we are concerned
the report that we've issued today went
up to the end of june
but we have put out also information
today talking about what has happened
since the conflict dynamics changed at
the end of june but we continue to see
violations and abuses being committed by
the ethiopian air australian forces and
by tigran forces we are very worried and
that's why the un high commissioner for
human rights michelle bashary today made
an impassioned plea for the violence to
stop and for the parties to ensure the
protection of civilians now ethiopian
prime minister abi ahmed we understand
has urged residents to arm themselves
and defend
this how dangerous is it if uh the line
between civilians and combatants is
blurred
well from a human rights perspective it
is incredibly important we always speak
about the impact of conflict on
civilians and it is clear that when
conflict is waged that the parties must
take all precautions to protect
civilians and that is something that we
have not seen we did not see and we have
documented it in our report there were
indiscriminate attacks on civilian
places such as schools and hospitals and
places of worship we heard from victims
and witnesses how people were killed in
shelling we've heard a whole range of
abuses and violations documented and
told to us by the people that we spoke
to for our report
now as you know there there has been no
let up in fighting there is an
intensification as a matter of fact
taking place who could mediate a
potential ceasefire the african union
the u.n
well i think it is very important that
of course the the parties to the
conflict in integrity uh get together
that they they
have a ceasefire that they are able to
engage in inclusive dialogue it is also
clearly important that the international
community plays a role because things
are deteriorating it is incredibly
worrying and our report today does lay
bare the complete
devastating impact that the conflict has
had and continues to have on civilians
remember the humanitarian situation in
the country is absolutely dire across
tigray afar and amhara there are seven
million people who are in dire need of
humanitarian assistance five million
alone in tigre and four hundred thousand
of those are in famic-like conditions so
it's absolutely urgent that the fighting
stops that there is a ceasefire and that
the parties get around the table to to
to talk and also that the parties
are able to investigate and hold
accountable those who have perpetrated
human rights violations and abuses now
it seems that all parties are treating
this strife as existential some
observers are calling the atrocities
that are happening ethiopia a genocide
but that word has not been used in this
uh report
is the u.n shying away from using such
terminology
no not shying away at all what the
report lays out is that what we found
the the the torture the indiscriminate
attacks the extrajudicial killings and
other violations and abuses may amount
to war crimes and crimes against
humanity and these are very serious
atrocity crimes now we don't speak of
genocide in a report but we do flag that
they they appear to be in instances of
ethnically driven violence and we're
saying that there needs to be further
investigation of this but just to
underscore we're saying that war crimes
and crimes against humanity may have
been committed and these are incredibly
serious crimes indeed
liz thrussell is a spokesperson for the
united nations human rights office in
geneva switzerland and she's been
talking to us about the un report on the
conflict in ethiopia thank you very much
for joining us thank you for your time
thank you